well ted with all that smoke we've been
dealing with lately it may be tough for
you to get outside walk or run right now
a new study finds that exercising at
night may have more benefits than we
realize dr trina moholt led a study in
norway closely monitoring the blood
glucose levels of overweight men who
were on a high fat diet the study
participants did five days of high
intensity interval training some
exercised in the morning some exercised
at night well like wade alexander who's
a busy father of two
i tend to go late in the evening between
10 pm and midnight some of my friends
think i'm a little crazy
they're already in bed by the time that
i'm just checking into the gym and
getting started
the study found both morning and night
exercise of course improves your fitness
and your oxygen intake but only evening
exercise lowered cholesterol and lowered
overnight glucose levels which could
help burn fat researchers need to
conduct a study on women though to see
if they experience the same kind of
benefits